there's a tension between the service
the ISPs the network service provides
the Internet service providers and the
people who run the big services like
Google like you know Amazon and these
large providers I play at BBC iPlayer
for example where the people who provide
the services who provide the content
need the network in order to deliver the
content to their customers the network
providers are the ones that have to pay
in some sense for the delivery of that
content that's what their business is
based around and so they would like to
be able to say if a particular service
starts getting very popular so suddenly
YouTube gets very popular in it haven't
been previously they might like to be
able to say well we could charge them
more for that traffic because it's in
demand and that means we can make more
money out of this whereas obviously the
people who provide the content would
rather they didn't do that because they
don't have to pay more for that so this
kind of debate is this tension about
around can you get more can you say sure
can you extract more value as a network
provider from doing what you do the
internet originally was written to
connecting different networks that
wouldn't develop I think mostly in the
u.s. sometimes of like the military
Network the ARPANET work and so on these
are all interconnected and it's grown
out of that into having lots of networks
connecting so you now have commercial
networks that interconnect into that
there is a rough notion of hierarchy in
the Internet in terms of the type of
network inside a network but it's fairly
ad hoc and it's sort of all evolving
over time as well so it used to be the
case that you had quite a clear core
network so you'd have I think break
they're about sort of five to ten of
these and these were networks that fully
connected to each other and then from
these you would have other networks
these networks that Tier one and then
you had other networks that would be
slightly smaller that's what we're
called here to imagine today and then
you'd have the sort of you kind of look
great from that and the smaller small
networks and so the idea was that if you
ended up down here at your house and a
packet got injected into this network
this network might not contain the
destination that backups trying to get
to bought it would do is it would
connect to other networks and it could
then translate this data so it came out
to the server that you wanted to get to
and it's that interconnection of
networks will be Internet
essentially so you're in this tier one
it probably means that you've got direct
peering links with all the other
networks in Tier one and that will be
two that will be based on a business
relationship with those networks and an
agreement that you've come to about how
much traffic you carry how much traffic
they carry how many people you can reach
how many people they can reach and so
you can't agree that you're both willing
to exchange traffic freely if you're in
a low inner sort of the higher tier so
in tier 2 tier on tier 1 then you're
probably going to be a customer of one
of those networks and so you'll have a
different type of arrangement in place
for paying for data transit frame don't
need to be data to be carried for
example so it's not really a it's not a
technical building you sub winning the
similar protocols right you're still
carrying 90 packets just like everybody
else is carrying like your packets it's
just that you can now call this
different business relationship oh yeah
yeah so I draw the diagrams like this as
if these are connected these are sort of
seemingly connected blobs
but in practice these are going to be
geographically spread around the whole
planet so actually there's a kind of
overlaying of multiple networks sort of
geographically on top of each other
almost that then interconnect at certain
points so one of these networks might be
Sprint's Network for example and they
will have points of presence where they
have reuters that you can connect to in
many many cities in the US and around
the rest of the world as well and there
will be multiple points of contacts
although again I've drawn it with a
single line here actually there's going
to be multiple places where these
different networks connect and it's
gonna it's gonna be much more complex
than this rather abstracted picture I
put here they're gonna be physically
overlapping and they're going to be
touching at multiple points let's take a
fictional streaming service love flicks
or net filled suddenly the technology
sorry more importantly the content
arrives in 4k super high definition yeah
and they decide that they're gonna
broadcast or stream this in 4k how will
that play out then so that you're on the
flicks or nets no I mean that film is
probably safer for my customers this
super new service you will have some
arrangement with the network providers
that your equipment sits in their
network or sits connected their network
and you'll be paying them some amount of
money for delivering your traffic
and so that potentially gonna be an
impact that suddenly you're now going to
much higher resolution which means you
need more bandwidth to deliver it which
means it it's more traffic which means
you can end up paying a lot more
potentially for that and then depending
on how that is structured there may be
different kinds of agreements in place
in terms of how that pricing works out
essentially in terms of the customer
kind of experience of that ideally what
you would like is you would like to have
that data fairly close to you the server
physically close to you so that it
doesn't take too long it so that you can
essentially get higher you can get lower
latency connecting to and you can
potentially get higher bandwidth
depending on how the rest of the network
is configured so so let's say this is
net film everybody from all around the
planet has to try and come in get data
from that server obviously there's going
to be a whole set of service here is not
it's going to be one but they might also
choose to put those servers in different
places so both different places
geographically in the same network so
that there's going to be one in the UK
so you can get stuff from that if you're
basically casing me for something in the
US so you can get something from there
but also connecting through different
networks so they might also choose to
put some servers in this other network
so that the customers of that network
will have something close to them in
network terms as well and the reason for
doing that then is that you will often
basically pay for moving traffic when it
goes between two networks but if you're
a customer of this network here then
it's probably going to be cheaper to
have the traffic do that and it is going
to be to have the traffic coming through
all these other networks to get to you
because there's less arrangements in
place and this provider is able to
manage that better so they'll both want
to geographically distributed service
and they'll also potentially want to
distribute it interpretational networks
where there are a large community of
users that are using it if they can move
some of their content drop it in to that
network then it means you get a better
performance and it's cheaper for them
because they don't have to pay something
they don't have pay for so much delivery
traffic so at the moment the customer is
playing for which part of this and which
is net film painful you'll have money
flowing this way because the customers
got to pay for that I think you'll have
money flowing this way because the
customers paying for that film and then
you'll also have money flowing from net
film I believe into the ISP networks
and you'll have money flowing perhaps
not between the tier ones because
they'll probably have some kind of
hearing arrangement where they've two
part two parties will decide that if the
ratio of traffic in and out is about the
same or within certain bounds
nobody needs to exchange house because
it's a benefit to both sides but you
will have money flowing that way from
the network provider into their network
so there's quite a lot of stuff going on
there and the benefit then for net film
are being able to put the server into
one of these networks is that it cuts
out some of the money that has change
hounds and the benefit for the network
provider is that it means that the
because the the data is going to
originate from within their network they
don't have to pay anybody else to
transiting it and it potentially reduces
the load they've got on and in their
network so often the links that are
inside the network will be higher
capacity comparatively and it offers
these links that go between networks
which are lower capacity or at least
whether that's for technical reasons or
something cuz you've got to pay for what
goes across those links so there's a
sort of benefit to both sides and net
filled get their data closer to the
users so it's easy for the user to get
into the experience and as benefit to
the network provider because they don't
have as much data having to transit the
expensive links
we like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this computerphile video
they've got loads of books online for
you to choose from if you want to try
one out for free go to audible.com slash
computerphile I asked not to rich and
multi a who featured in this video for
recommendation and he recommended Boland
by Alan Garner it's narrated as well by
Robert Powell which is fantastic so get
over to audible.com maybe try out Boland
on dr. more tears recommendation try out
a book for free at audible.com/asap
eautiful thanks once again to them for
sponsoring this computerphile video and
so what's going to happen is you've got
some data that starts out on your
browser so that's the request and then
that's going to get sent down through
these libraries eventually into the
operating system and what's going to
happen there is that this chunk which is
your original data maybe he's going to
get encoded as a TCP segment